life on Earth has existed for billions
of years humans know this not because
we've been around the whole time but
instead thanks to the discovery of
fossils which tell us about organisms
that lived in the distant past
scientists have found millions of
fossils some such as skeletons document
ancient organisms Anatomy or physical
features While others such as preserved
Footprints record organisms behaviors
each fossil that has been found is like
a piece of a giant puzzle to see the
bigger picture of the history of life on
Earth
scientists have to study the many
fossils and see how they all fit
together in the larger puzzle all the
fossil puzzle pieces that have been
discovered along with their relative
ages make up Earth's fossil record the
fossil record is basically a history of
life on Earth as documented through
fossils by studying the fossil record
scientists can see how life on Earth has
changed over evolutionary time
the fossil record allows us to see
patterns of evolutionary changes that
have happened throughout Earth's history
these include an overall increase in
organism complexity and diversity and
the changes that have occurred along
evolutionary lineages showing us how one
group of organisms could have evolved to
the next
the fossil record also shows us when
certain groups of organisms went extinct
first let's take a look at the increase
in organism complexity and diversity
that is seen in the fossil record
over evolutionary time organisms have
generally become more complicated some
of the oldest known fossils are
formations made by ancient colonies of
cyanobacteria
these fossils provide evidence that
single-celled organisms were living on
Earth roughly around 3.5 billion years
ago and that these organisms were
relatively simple similar to the
bacteria we have today
the fossil record then goes on to
document major leaps and complexity of
the life on Earth
with for example the large tube-shaped
cells of grappania spiralis and the
macroscopic organisms in the French
civilian biota
according to scientists these fossils
which are dated to be roughly from 2
billion years ago could provide evidence
of some of the earliest eukaryotic or
nucleus-containing cells and of the
earliest multicellular organisms
not only does the fossil record show an
increase in complexity over evolutionary
time but also an increase in the
diversity of life on Earth
for example the Cambrian explosion
describes a multi-million year span of
time beginning about
539 million years ago in which there was
a huge increase in the diversity of
animals on earth almost all of the
animal lineages we know today actually
got started during this period
all of these increases in complexity and
diversity have given rise to the
millions of varied organisms that live
on Earth today next let's take a look at
the changes that can be seen along the
evolutionary lineages in the earth's
fossil record but before we do that
let's quickly look back at how
scientists study fossils
as you may recall fossils are found in
sedimentary rocks meaning that the
deeper the fossil the older the fossil
is likely to be
So based on the layers in which the
fossil is found scientists can put them
in order by age and in doing this
scientists can piece together The
evolutionary steps of how one type of
organism could have evolved into the
next eventually giving rise to the
living organisms we see today
to give an example of this did you know
that birds are actually direct
descendants of a group of dinosaurs
called theropods it may be hard to
believe but the fossil record shows that
an organism known as archeopteryx
existed about 150 million years ago
towards the end of the dinosaur age but
before the appearance of modern Birds
this organism in particular is
interesting because it had some features
unique to theropod dinosaurs such as
jaws and sharp teeth and some features
unique to birds such as feathers so
archeopteryx represents an evolutionary
transition between theropod dinosaurs
and birds in the fossil record
finally let's take a look at the
patterns of Extinction seen in the
fossil record with the help of our
extinct friend the Triceratops
Extinction happens when a species
completely dies out in the fossil record
extinctions show up as organisms of a
certain species being present in older
rock layers and then completely
disappearing from the newer Rock layers
for example we only see Triceratops
fossils and rock layers that are roughly
68 to 66 million years old
after this we don't find any evidence of
Triceratops fossils anywhere and there
certainly aren't any Triceratops living
today
the Triceratops is an important example
of Extinction as they not only went
extinct but they went extinct due to a
mass extinction event
mass extinction events happened when
large-scale environmental change caused
many grooves of organisms to go extinct
around the same time when we see the
Triceratops disappear from the fossil
record we also see other types of
organisms disappear too providing
evidence for the mass extinction event
that led to The Disappearance of all
non-avian dinosaurs and with that you
now know what Earth's fossil record is
and the various patterns it can show us
Earth's fossil record is an essential
tool that scientists use to piece
together the history of life on Earth
and new fossils are continuously being
discovered so the fossil record is more
than just a collection of fossils it's a
window into the mysteries of the past
and its ever-growing record of how life
on Earth came to be what it is today